économie environnement énergie
eau social
le développement durable à la Réunion
c'est maintenant
bonjour je m'appelle Benoît je suis
codée au collège Jean descends je vais
vous présenter un éco-geste qui permet
d'économiser l'eau à la cantine à la fin
des repas nous récupérons l'eau des Bros
pour arroser les plantes
pour réaliser votre système goutte à
goutte il vous faut une bouteille percer
les trous à l'arrière de votre bouteille
pour créer un appel d'air il vous faut
aussi un distributeur d'eau au goutte à
goutte
on peut fabriquer le système que tu as
goutte en passant un bouchon mais le
problème c'est que l'eau s'écoule très
rapidement nous avons opté pour un
système en terre cuite acheté dans le
commerce l'eau s'écoule très lentement
par les tout petits pores de la terre
cuite avec une bouteille d'un lit de 25
votre plante est arrosée pendant une
semaine
pour installer votre bouteille
d'arrosage il vous suffit de la remplir
d'eau puis de la planter à la base de la
plante
il ne vous reste plus qu'à la surveiller
et à la remplir un télé vide
économiser jusqu'à 130 euros sur mes
factures d'eau comment je prends une
douche plutôt qu'un bain je ferme mon
robinet le temps de me laver les mains
les dents ou en me rasant je n'utilise
le lave-vaisselle et le lave-linge que
s'ils sont pleins je choisis une chasse
d'eau économique je récupère les eaux de
pluie pour effectuer des tâches comme le
nettoyage ou l'arrosage du jardin
j'arrose le jardin pendant les heures
les plus fraîches de la journée
c'est-à-dire tout le matin ou à la
tombée de la nuit je lave mon véhicule
une fois par mois à la maison ou dans
une station-service et non dans la
ravine alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est d'augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat le Conseil Général agit
pour le développement durable et vous
économie environnement énergie
eau social
le développement durable à la Réunion
c'est maintenant